here to discuss Florida Congressman Matt
Gates Texas Congressman chip Roy so Chip
let me start with you tonight so up
until I guess some point today earlier
today uh you did have and a stop Gap
measure you had your house Freedom
caucus uh sponsoring a deal making a
deal with the more moderate mainstream
call stream caucus that would impose an
eight percent spending cut on federal
agencies not including national uh not
including the National Defense budget
the Department of Veterans Affairs or
any amounts designated for disaster
relief and that would fund the
government through October 31st so my
question is what happened to that deal
and where do we go from here
yeah Sean good to be on I mean first of
all everything you just said we should
as Republicans have already passed 12
Appropriations bills that would deal
with all of those policies issues you
just described and cut the overall
spending level that is what we should
have done we have not done that so now
we're sitting here in September and
we're trying to figure out what we need
to do next uh today unfortunately we
voted down a Department of Defense
Appropriations bill that would have cut
the abortion tourism cut transgender
surgeries cut Chief diversity officers
cut diversity Equity inclusion because
of the great work we did trying to force
conservatives onto Appropriations
committees and similarly to the question
you just asked we put forward a bill
that would have cut spending to all of
the non-defense non-veteran bureaucracy
by eight percent and attached to it H2
the strongest border security Bill we've
ever passed to try to check Joe Biden's
open borders we wanted to tell Democrats
you should either shut down the Border
or you're going to deal with a shutdown
government unfortunately now we are in
danger of turning over home field
advantage to the Democrats and giving
Democrats power to make the decisions
next week rather than doing our job I
think that's a mistake some of my
colleagues in good faith including the
one who's just about to talk who's a
friend of mine I think we made a bad
choice this week I think we could have
moved forward now we've got to figure
out how to set a Top Line number and try
to move Appropriations bills like we
should have done uh all the way back in
July all right the house tried voting on
the rule for the dod defense
Appropriations here
um Matt was that voting against even
bringing up the bill or having a
discussion and voting on it and the 170
amendments that I guess you can add to a
bill like that and and let's talk about
what what's on your agenda here you are
a leading critical voice of of speaker
McCarthy what do you want and how is
this going to proceed and do you agree
that Republicans win or lose together
one way or the other they won't be some
winners and some losers you either win
together or lose together
I can assure you that speaker McCarthy
deserves all the criticism and more
because it's his fault that we haven't
considered individual Appropriations
bills up to this point and that's
actually not a bug of the system it's a
feature because they want to jam us at
the end of the government running out of
money and then under that time pressure
and the fear of a shutdown centralized
power so that the lobbyists and the
special interests who own Kevin McCarthy
who give him all the money get to make
the decisions now today I agreed with
chip Roy that we should have proceeded
onto the defense Appropriations bill I
would have voted for that bill we were
not able to proceed because some of my
colleagues didn't feel like Kevin
McCarthy was in compliance with the
agreement in January to constrain
himself to a top-line spending level
that did not embrace the ballooning
budgets of bidenism and covetism so my
plan is not to lump every disparate
agency of government into one vote on a
continuing resolution but instead dead
to only review these things separately
and independently that is the serious
way to go about this work chip is right
we will have a shutdown but I don't
believe that an eight percent 30-day cut
would have yielded the programmatic
reforms that would create any long-term
savings the only way to do that
amendments individual bills no more
continuing resolutions or Omnibus we
have the moderate Wing now threatening a
clean CR which would be a loss for
anybody that believes in fiscal
responsibility you have even Mitch
McConnell admonishing the you members of
the House for dairy to even consider
fiscal responsibility I think the
irresponsible one is him in this
particular case because I think spending
levels are too high 2 trillion in new
debt this year alone at what point is
enough enough so my question to you is
I'm glad that leader McConnell can
muster an admonishment he must be
feeling better but when it comes to a
clean CR if house moderates want to join
with Democrats to advance every feature
of the Biden government thinking that
that's going to be good for them
politically they will be signing their
own political death warrant and handing
it to their executioner because it won't
be conservatives going after those
moderates in the midterm in the next
elections it'll be the very Democrats
that they're in Coalition with and you
know what Sean if your viewers in this
country are really governed by a una
party then let's go ahead and expose
that and people like chip Roy and I will
be fighting against it for Less spending
and to defang this woken weaponized
government all right so I guess chip the
the question is and I think Matt brings
up a lot of good points here I mean how
do if we're going to put the American
people first and fiscal responsibility
is key 33 trillion for most people I
guess it becomes million billion
trillion 33 trillion just imagine that
number that we're putting on our kids
and grandkids 2 trillion in new debt
under Biden this year alone so you know
give me a solution that benefits the
people of this country that's who I know
you both want to serve and suppose Lee
your fellow members want to serve
yeah Sean let me look I couldn't agree
more and again Matt and I are equally
committed uh and on the same team in
terms of what we're trying to do to push
back on the bite Administration and cut
spending look the issue here is and the
reason I was supportive of putting
forward a proposal that would have
advanced spending for literally 30 days
with an eight percent cut to federal
spending into the federal bureaucracy
and moved the hr2 border security bills
because Sean my state of Texas is under
assault people are dying people are
dying from fentanyl poisoning little
children are getting sold in the sex
trafficking trade and I wanted to hang
that around Chuck Schumer's neck I
wanted him to have to go back to the
people of New York and say you know what
all that you're facing here in New York
I'm going to ignore that you know what
I'm more interested in an open border
than in making sure that we actually
closed the border and instead of
government that's the reality what's the
strategy going forward
well I mean right now we're in a
position where we're I'm literally in
the capital I'm going to go back
downstairs trying to figure out a Top
Line number that will get 218
Republicans United to move forward with
Appropriations bills and again I wish
we'd have done this months ago we're
working towards trying to do it but look
it's a bit of an uphill climb because I
do believe that there are members of the
Republican conference who are about
right on the verge of working a deal
with Democrats in which case we end up
with a continuing resolution that funds
into December at the Pelosi levels and
we may end up with Ukraine funding or
emergency spending on top of it I'd like
to stand in front of that that's why I
put forward a proposal that I thought
would cut spending secure the border of
the United States that's where I think
we ought to go we ought to be beating
the heck out of Democrats over what
they're doing to open borders and their
spending we had a way to do it and
unfortunately we didn't take that path
so now I'm down here working and trying
to figure out what's next all right so
Matt let me go to you and I agree with
both of you I think individual
Appropriations bills the appropriation
Bills should have been passed there's no
excuse for that especially when you are
in control of the house albeit a small
majority but that is a reality you are
dealing with moderate voices in that
caucus apparently ones that would even
do a deal with the Democrats so I ask
you now dealing with the reality of
where we are going forward what works
for you what can you and Chip put on a
whiteboard and and get that caucus to
buy into 218 of you anyway
yeah I can probably tell you that I'll
support any Top Line number that chip
Roy can support that's the trust I have
in him as a fiscal conservative but what
I won't do is pick the Border fight by
surrendering every other fight and then
saying well you know we'll give Biden
everything he wants and everything but
the border and we think that's good
politics On the Border instead what I
would propose is pick the Border fight
by advancing our Appropriations bill for
the Department of Homeland Security and
you know what else we should do to pick
a border fight impeach my orcas he
deserves it he is violating our laws now
as as good as the federal chip road is
you know yeah but but see that's the way
to do it
on the Democrats uh you know side of the
field instead we ought to be in the
business of offense not continuing
resolutions that lump elements of
government together that have nothing to
do with one another
all right let me put out a scenario
let's say you guys are able to get
together and you pull 18 to 818 votes
together uh and I think these other
votes Appropriations a month more added
on to it that's enough time they need to
get their job done my question is is
really simple then you're going to have
to reconcile with the Senate I don't
think Mitch McConnell of moderates in
the Senate support even responsible
spending so you go to conference what
happens in conference what then becomes
acceptable because now you're definitely
going to water it down at least they'll
be insisting on it and how long are you
guys want to let the government shut
down in the process chip
well first of all I'm not 100 sure that
we're going to get the shutdown for the
reasons I was just articulating in terms
of some of our colleagues that are
talking to some of our other colleagues
on the other side of the aisle but if we
were to get there I certainly think we
should ride it out as long as we can to
force our Senate you know colleagues to
the table but you've got to send the
right conferees to the table today was a
good sign on the National Defense
authorization act that that we've got a
few of our conservatives from hfc on the
uh conference you know committee but uh
now right now our first job is to get
some legislation out of the house send
it over to the Senate that represents
our priorities at the right spending
levels that's what we've got to do we've
got to focus like a laser American
people sent us here to actually stand up
for them against the Biden Democrat
machine we've got to send bills out of
this house that represent our spending
levels and policy priorities all right
Matt we'll give you the last word
yeah one thing chip and I agree on for
sure is that the best way to prepare for
a conference that is successful for the
American people is for the House of
Representatives to start with the most
conservative position not for us to try
to meet Mitch McConnell halfway before
even getting to what will be necessary
to save the country so gosh if we had
the White House and we had the Border
bill that chip put together and we had
individual spending bills we might just
have one last best hope to save this
country from Financial ruin publicans
need to pay attention if you don't
distinguish yourself in the house on the
issue of balanced budget spending and
not putting debt on our children
where are you going to fight where's
what are you there for thank you both
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else